Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. Tonight we're
going to be talking about predictive
programming. I always like these kind of
decodes where we take take some kind of
mainstream media, whether it's a movie,
a game, a cartoon or something, and
break down the prophetic codes that are
inside there. Because Satan uses this
entertainment as his Bible, his way to
promote prophecies, his agendas. And
there's a a famous quote, I don't know
exactly who it's by, some Freemason, it
might be Albert Pike, that is it goes
along the lines of symbols are to hide
things from those who do not have eyes
to see and to reveal it to those who do.
So basically, a lot of entertainment has
these occult symbols in there, Masonic
symbols, things that to the average
person who's never went down the rabbit
hole, never had an awakening of what's
going on in these secret societies that
rule the world, we just think, "Oh,
these are trendy little icons or
whatever, an allseeing eye, uh,
pyramids,
pentagrams, all that stuff." But in
reality, these things are signaling
people who know what's up. People who
are aware of these symbols and God has
revealed to me and many other people
these things and have woke us up from
the slumber that we were in and have
given us a gift of discernment to be
able to see through these uh this
propaganda and what it's promoting. So,
I don't know if anybody remembers this
movie called Contact. It came out in
and it's about a driven SETI. So SETI
means search for extraterrestrial
intelligence. It's a real life uh
organization that's been around since at
least when I was in high school. I
actually used to pay attention to this
SETI thing. I had an app where I could
pay attention to anything that's going
on out in the universe. Are they hearing
any kind of uh artificial signals?
Something that's not natural. That's
what it's all about. search for
extraterrestrial intelligence. a driven
SETI scientist who dedicates her life to
finding extraterrestrial intelligence
and finally detects a complex signal
from space containing blueprints for a
machine leading to global debate,
political conflict, and an incredible
journey through wormholes where she
encounters alien life exploring themes
of science versus faith, belief, and
humanity's place in the cosmos. most
based on Carl Sean's novel novel. So
Carl Sean was basically the 70s version
of Neil Degrasse Tyson. Okay, that's who
he was. And he always did these shows
about space and the cosmos and what
could be out there and it was he was
just pushing propaganda back then all
about extraterrestrial life. This is how
the opening scene of the movie starts.
So you can see it's out here in the
cosmos and it's zooming back, back, back
until finally
you see something interesting. I just
think there's no symbolism that's
mistake. Okay? Everything in Hollywood
is done on purpose. It's all scripted,
screenplay, it set design, everything.
Nothing is by accident. Okay? So when
this thing zooms out and shows
a single eyeball.
>> That's not an accident. Okay, they're
already setting the tone of the movie in
the very first intro. Okay, it shows
Earth. It shows like a lot of uh radio
signals and and then it it backs up and
it gets, you know, quiet in the deadness
of space and the vacuum of space and it
comes out of this little girl's eyeball.
She's the main character who eventually
becomes the grownup Jodie Foster. Okay,
now check this out right here already.
So, we've already seen the single
eyeball and then it goes to the girl's
room where she's talking to her dad.
He's putting her to bed and you can see
the owl on the wall, the Bohemian Grove
Moolock owl. And you can see the monarch
mind control butterfly on her blankets.
Okay, this is none of this is by
accident. Okay, none of this was like,
"Oh, let's just we need a blanket from
the thrift store. Go buy something." All
of this is set design. Okay,
now listen to this scene right here
because this girl's mom has passed away.
Her dad is the only one that's alive.
And listen to this conversation here.
>> Could we talk to Jupiter or or what's
the one after that? Uh, don't tell me.
I'll give you a hint.
>> Hula hoops.
>> Saturn. Could we talk to Saturn?
>> Mhm.
>> Dad, could we talk to mom?
>> I don't think even the biggest radio
could reach that far.
>> So, we already see that it's setting up,
you know, it's it's got all this
Illuminati symbolism straight from the
beginning. the the the single eye, the
owl on her wall, the butterfly
comforter, and now it's setting the
stage for spiritualism. Okay. She's
asking her dad, "You think that I could
listen?" Because she she plays around
with a CB radio and she's, you know,
talking to people. She's trying to see
how far can she talk to people and she's
got a little map. You'll see in the the
next scene here. and she's showing how
far she can talk to people and she asked
her dad, "Do you think we could talk to
mom?" And he says, "I don't think
there's a CV or like a satellite strong
enough." Okay,
so her name is Dr. Eleanor Anne and she
goes by Ellie Arrowway. Okay, these
names aren't picked out of a hat. ages
of people, their names, their character,
everything is strategic. It all has
purpose and meaning. If you're one of
these people that think, "Come on, man.
You're thinking way too deep about it."
That is a slap in the face to the writer
and the director to tell them like,
"It's just mindless entertainment. It's
not that deep. Everything is
purposeful." Now, what does the name
Eleanor mean? Eleanor is a classic
feminine name of French Greek origin
meaning shining light, bright one or sun
ray. So we know that Satan is the
lightbearer that his biggest masquerade
is the the sun, right? Trying to get all
the world to worship the sun.
And that's how all through out history,
cultures have worshiped the sun and
they're actually worshiping Satan. So,
her name is the sun. She's the
lightbearer. So, already she's the
protagonist, but we see this gnostic
flip. If you don't know about
gnosticism, check out Little Light
Studios. They got a lot of videos on
Gnostic themes that are in movies. But
basically, it's the inverted gospel
that's in nearly every Hollywood movie.
Whether it's Truman's Show or
um The Matrix or Pleasantville, all
these movies have a Gnostic theme where
the hero has more in common with Satan
and the bad guy has more in common with
God. And you'll see it over and over.
So, here we we have this same thing. The
protagonist, she is the son and she's a
feminine. We're going to get into that.
And here's where she's, you know,
pinning on the board how far she can
actually communicate and listen to what
he calls her.
>> Pensacola, Florida.
I have to tell you, Sparks,
1,116
miles.
>> All right. The names aren't pulled out
of a hat. These numbers aren't just made
up. Okay. He called her Sparks. So, her
name is Eleanor. call there also Ellie,
but he calls her Sparks. And then he
says that she just communicated with
Pensacola, Florida. That's 1,116
miles away. Now, when you break that
down, you got 111, which is 3 and 6. 36
or triple 6. You add them all together,
you get nine, which is also an occult
number like 911 and the inversion of
six. None of this is by coincidence.
Okay? This is all strategic. It all has
meaning. This is I I Googled this asking
is there any kind of um esoteric meaning
to this number and it's saying 1116
reduces in numerology as 1 + 1 + 1 + 6 =
9 or sometimes kept as the master number
series 111 meaning keep that separate
from the six there with the six. So 111
which means three and six 36.
The number nine relates to completion,
humanitarianism and spiritual
enlightenment. This whole movie is going
to be a propaganda piece about entering
into the age of Aquarius. Spiritual
enlightenment, communication with
aliens, which is really some kind of
spiritual shift. Okay, this is exactly
what this movie is all about. And this
thing came out in 1997. I think it was
666 reduced in numerology as 6 plus 6
plus 6= 18 and 1 and 8 equ= 9. So they
both are simplified to the number nine.
Now remember he called her spark. Her
nickname is spark. When you look at what
that means innosticism it's the divine
spark. Anasticism, the divine spark is
the portion of God that resides within
each human being. All right? This isn't
saying, "Oh, if you accept Christ, he
lives within you." This is saying we
innately have God in us, that we can
reach Christ's consciousness and all
this stuff. The purpose of life is to
enable the divine spark to be released
from its captivity in matter. Gnostics
believe that this physical body, this
physical realm is actually a prison and
we need to uh evolve into the spiritual
realm. And so they would say you're
you're not allowed to marry. You're not
allowed to eat pleasurable foods. All
these things are sinful to the body and
you have to preserve your body like like
monks. And then you reach Christ
consciousness. You evolve into a
spiritual entity, a spiritual being. And
that's the divine spark reaching that
place. So her name is Spark. She's the
lightbearer. She's the spark, the divine
spark. This is allnosticism.
I'm showing here some uh I highlighted
how many times the word spark shows up
in this gnostic article. I'm not going
to read this whole thing, but you see
spark spark light spark possession of
the spark essential spark light spark
light spark the sparks of light to
himself.
And then it says right here it says uh
about halfway down himself with the
Sophia as the bridegroom. Who is Sophia
innosticism?
We're going to look at that. This is a
article right here about gnosticism and
you'll see that Sophia is a figure along
with knowledge or nosis among many of
the early Christians knowledge
theologies grouped by the heresiologist
I can't read these words um knowing
nosis means knowing so when you're
gnostic they say that they have all
knowledge they have reached
enlightenment
what was promised in the Garden of Eden.
Eat this fruit and your eyes will be
open. You'll become like God. You're
going to know everything. You'll have
the divine spark. You'll become a
spiritual being. This goes all the way
back to the Garden of Eden. That's
whatnosticism is. It's Luciferian
doctrine. Now, right here, it's saying
that Sophia Sophia is a parallel to that
serpent in the garden.
Sophia is the one that came into the
garden and told Adam and Eve to eat this
fruit because their creator God has them
in this um perfect garden prison and
he's trying to keep them from knowledge
innosticism. Sophia is a feminine figure
analogous
to the human soul but also
simultaneously one of the feminine
aspects of God. Gnostics held that she
was the
saigi
sasai or feminine twin of Jesus. All
right, I'm not going to read all this,
but I want you to see that Sophia is
the serpent character in the story.
Right here, you actually see it. It
says, "Yes, in many Gnostic traditions,
Sophia or divine wisdom is the serpent
in the Garden of Eden appearing to offer
Adam and Eve the forbidden fruit of
knowledge or nosis to awaken them from
the ignorance imposed by the demi urge,
the false creator, God, Yahweh. Thus
transforming the serpent from a deceiver
into a divine liberator and savior
figure." That's whatnosticism is. that
Lucifer was actually a good being that
came in the garden to set Adam and Eve
free to give them knowledge to awaken
them that their eyes would be open that
they would become like God. Okay, so she
represents Sophia. She's the divine
spark. She's the lightbearer.
Right here we got more on this topic.
Sophianosticism. Anasticism. Sophia is a
feminine divine figure. Um, notice it
says right here that she is seen as the
link between the divine and material
worlds. So there's this woman, divine
female figure that is a link between the
divine or the spiritual world and the
material world. Keep that in mind.
Remember that because that's exactly
what this movie is about. It's about
this woman
uniting the spiritual world and the
material world together.
Now see it says pursuit of knowledge.
Ellie is defined by her relentless
almost innate drive to seek the seek
knowledge and truth about the universe
reflecting the core meaning of Sophia as
wisdom. Her journey is a quest for
profound ultimate truth which is a
central theme in innostic thought. So, I
just asked Google, "Is there a Gnostic
theme in this movie Contact?" And it's
breaking it down. And I'm telling you,
I've said this before. Google is one of
the biggest pieces of propaganda.
They're not going to give you some
conspiracy theory type of idea. They're
censoring all that and they're saying
they're the biggest skeptic. They're
saying, "No, that's that's a conspiracy
theory or whatever." The third paragraph
here says, "Spiritual transformation.
Ellie underos a profound
ineffable experience that transcends the
physical world, bringing her an inner
truth that she cannot physically prove
to others. That's what happens in the
movie later on. This personal mystical
knowledge that defies conventional
evidence mirrors the Gnostic emphasis on
direct internal revelation or nosis over
external proof. the female mystic. Some
analysis characterize Ellie as a female
mystic. So, it's not just me. I'm not
just like picking this out of any out of
thin air. Other people have caught on to
this who experience a journey beyond the
scope of normal human understanding,
challenging established maledominated
structures, both scientific and
religious. This aligns with Sophia's
unique and often marginalized role in
some patriarchal interpretations of
divinity. Okay? So, if you believe in
the creator God of the Bible, you are
some patriarchal interpretation of
divinity. You don't believe that there
could be a a female god.
But everything about this is saying that
she is Sophia. She's the one that's
bringing wisdom. She's the one that's
connecting the spiritual world with the
scientific world. This is crazy. All
right, listen to this clip.
>> I know it's hard to understand this now,
but
we aren't always meant to know the
reasons why things happen the way they
do.
Sometimes we just have to accept it as
God's will.
>> Should have kept some medicine in the
downstairs bathroom.
Then I could have gotten to it sooner.
So this is where as a little girl she
has lost her faith because her dad now
her dad died. So her mom died I think at
her birth and now she's 9 years old. Her
dad has died and this Catholic priest is
saying you know some things we just
don't understand you know and she's
thinking well she's thinking rationally
if I would have had the medicine closer
he'd be alive right now.
And so
she hasn't really lost faith yet, I
don't guess, because right here she's
trying to connect with her dead father
over this CB. Listen,
>> Dad. This is Ellie. Come back.
>> This is Eleanor. Airway transmitting on
14.2 megahertz.
Dad,
are you there?
Come back,
>> Dad.
>> All right. So, remember at the very
beginning, she asked her dad, "Do you
think we could connect with my dead mom
with this CB?" And he said, "I don't
think there's a satellite powerful
enough." Well, now her dad just died,
and now she's using technology to try
and communicate with her dead father.
This is opening up the door to
divination. This is giving Satan a
foothold. This is giving the enemy an
open door when you do things like uh
pull out tarot cards or play with a
Ouija board or use crystals or
dreamcatchers or any of these divination
tools. You are giving a signal to the
spirit world. I want to communicate and
I'm giving you permission into my life.
And this is these are things that we do
unaware. Sometimes we don't even know
that we've given Satan this open door.
But now she's done it as a nine-year-old
kid. She's talking into the communi into
the the technology, the communication,
and saying, "Dad, can you hear me?"
She's trying to communicate with her
dead father. Now, we know according to
the Bible that the dead are dead. The
dead know nothing. They praise not the
Lord. They return not to their house. to
communicate with the dead is necromancy
and it's forbidden by God because it's
literally communication with demons.
That's all it is.
So, she grows up to work at SETI and
she's always, you know, watching the
monitors and listening with headphones
and people think she's wasting her time
because she's listening to dead air and
space and sometimes she just has natural
static, but she's trying to listen for
some kind of unnatural communication,
some kind of artificial communication
that's coming from intelligent life out
there. Now, right here in the movie is
where she actually hears something and
she's she's going nuts like what was the
number on the screen and all that stuff
and the number on the screen is
1221.
When you look up what 1221 is in the an
angel numbers, it has to do with
enlightenment. Oh, big coincidence. Eat
this fruit, your eyes will be open.
You'll be enlightened. You'll evolve
like nasticism. When you keep reading,
you'll see that it just continues on and
it says, "Angel number 1221 signifies
personal growth or reaching Christ
consciousness and enlightenment through
divine messages." So, what is this
signaling? That whatever message she's
receiving from the heavens is a divine
message. A message from some gods out
there.
It combines energies of numbers one and
two emphasizing new beginnings. Remember
the uh the phoenix rising out of the
ashes, the new beginnings, the new world
order, balance and harmony encourages
trust and intuition.
Trust in intuition. What do you think
intuition is? You know this is saying
that you can trust your feelings, your
emotions, your gut feeling. embracing
positive change.
Change again, embracing a shift into the
age of Aquarius, the golden age as Trump
has called it, or as Helena Bavotssky
and Alice Bailey said, the
externalization of the hierarchy, the
golden age. That's what we're being told
over and over that we are entering into
this shift in our spiritual realm
and cultivating balance in love, career,
and personal growth. Have you been
noticing the number one 122 appearing in
your life? All right, I'm not going to
read all that, but it's saying it's a
divine message from the spiritual realm
and it can carry a unique message. The
master number 22. Furthermore, this is
on a website. Okay, this is on this
angel number website. Furthermore, the
sum of the digits in 1 22 1 or 1 + 2 + 2
+ 1 equals 6. The magic number six that
always appears reduces to the number six
which is closely linked to the master
number 22. The master builder, think
grand architect from the Freemasons,
right? a master builder number. This
powerful vibration resonates with vision
particularly or practically and a strong
sense of service to humanity. When angel
number 1221 appears, it may be a call to
use your natural talents and resources
to contribute to the greater good. If
you haven't kept up with the things that
Pope Francis was always talking about
this um this encyclical that he has
about getting rid of climate change and
enforcing Sunday and all this stuff and
making everyone all religions come
together and this big ecumenical
movement. It was always called the
greater good. He was talking about the
greater good all the time.
Trusting your intuition.
Angel number 1221 also emphasizes the
importance of trusting your intuition
and inner guidance. The repeated
appearance of number one suggests that
you have the power to create your own
reality through your thoughts, beliefs,
and actions by tapping into your innate
wisdom. Again, the wisdom and following
the quiet whispers of your soul. The
Bible says the heart is deceitful above
all things and desperately wicked. Who
can know it? We are not supposed to
follow your heart as Disney would say
but this is what this is is talking
about following your intuition.
He goes on to say embracing new
beginnings or a shift into the age of
Aquarius or the new world order the
repeated presence of one and 1221
represents the energy of new starts
personal empowerment. It's talking about
shedding the old patterns uh and
beliefs, the old patterns and beliefs,
the Christian beliefs in order to align
with your highest potential. You got to
get rid of those old dogmatic
religious Bible beliefs. They're holding
you back. That's what the serpent said
in the garden, right? God is keeping
knowledge from you. You can evolve into
a higher being if you just eat this
fruit and disobey God and rebel against
his perfect order.
Trusting the guidance of your angels.
When you see one 221, it's a clear sign
that your guardian angel and spiritual
guides are surrounding you. And it says
you are not alone in your journey. And
notice the last line says embracing the
power of positive change. Again about
change. Look, even Christians get sucked
into this whole angel number thing. Let
me tell you, the Bible says absolutely
nothing about angel numbers. Do not get
sucked into this 11-11. Oo, I saw 11-11
on the clock. It's my angel talking to
me. Don't fall for this deception. Even
Christians get sucked into yoga,
meditation, tarot cards, believe it or
not, they call them angel cards and even
Ouija boards and they call them angel
boards. Do not fall for this. If you
have started dabbling in this, please
look into this. It's a satanic
deception.
It goes on to say, um, this angel number
may signific signify a turning point. I
think that's very interesting with
what's going on with TurningPoint USA.
It says, "Instead of resisting or
fearing the unknown, 1221 urges you to
approach these transitions with an open
mind and a positive attitude, trusting
that the universe has your best interest
at heart."
Now, this part, honoring duality and
balance. Honor the duality and balance.
Do you know what duality is? Duality is
the yin and yang. It's saying, "Embrace
the good with the evil." Just like the
serpent said about the the knowledge of
good and evil. God said, "I don't want
you to have knowledge of evil. I don't
want you to know about murder and and
death and all these things. I only want
you to know about good things." But
there's this tree of knowledge that you
can eat from and you can have a balance,
a duality. You can know good and evil, a
balance of good and evil.
And so here she is in her office and
notice the checkerboard floors. That's
not by mistake. That wasn't just some
designer like, "Oh, I think this would
look cool." No, it was somebody was told
you must put the checkerboard floor
under Ellie the Lightbearer,
where the movie starts with her eyeball
and her room has an owl and the
butterfly, monarch butterfly, and she's
called the divine spark. None of this is
by accident. This is the yin and yang of
duality. And religious dualism is the
belief that the world is governed by two
fundamental opposing and often equally
powerful principles like good versus
evil, light versus dark, spirit versus
matter, or sacred versus profane.
explaining his existence as a cosmic
struggle between these forces. Famously
seen in Zoaritarianism
andnosticism.
It always comes back to nasticism. It
contrasts with monism. One principle or
monotheism, one supreme god. So the idea
of duality spits in the face of there
being one God, one truth, one way. It's
about embracing
a balance of good and evil. Gnosticism
over and over. So we've seen how all
this stuff relates back to nasticism.
She's the Sophia character. She's on the
checkerboard floor.
Now this you might think is a stretch.
She's out here with a guy or Yeah, she's
out here with a guy pointing to the
stars, but she's pointing with two
fingers. I just think that's kind of an
unnatural way to point. Call it a
stretch if you want, but I'm building a
case here. I'm adding to the evidence.
The single eye, the owl, the monarch
butterfly, her name's Spark, she's the
lightbearer, Eleanor, checkerboard
floor, the
1221 number that means a shift in
consciousness
to a spiritual realm. All of this is
purposeful.
Now, listen to this conversation right
here. Now, there are 400 billion stars
out there just in our galaxy alone.
If only one out of a million of those
had planets. All right? And if just one
out of a million of those had life, and
if just one out of a million of those
had intelligent life,
there would be literally millions of
civilizations out there.
Well, if there wasn't,
it' be an awful waste of space.
>> All right. When it comes to the alien
topic, this is the number one the number
one
uh line of thinking where people believe
in aliens. I've seen videos of the black
and white days and somebody would walk
up to people on the street, do you
believe in aliens? No, that's sci-fi
stuff. 90% of people said no. But I've
personally gone on the street and out of
all the people I asked, I think one
possibly two said they didn't believe in
aliens. Out of those that said that they
believe in aliens, 100% of them said
that they would trust them if they came
here to give us knowledge. I asked them,
I said, "If, okay, since you believe in
aliens, if they came, would you trust
them?" And they said, "Yeah, they're
smarter than us and all this stuff." not
even a a a shred of doubt that these
things could be deceivers or demonic or
evil in any kind of way. Where did this
come from? Where did this shift in
mindset come from? Well, the idea that
we're in an everexpanding universe. It's
a vacuum that just keeps expanding and
there's billions and trillions and
innumerable universes and worlds out
there. That idea didn't used to exist.
When people read the Bible and the Bible
alone, it says that the luminaries are
under our firmament. But over the years,
there was this big bang idea and this
every everything's expanding and now
we're saying, "Oh yeah, you can see far
away and you can't even count the number
of worlds that are out there." It would
be narcissistic to think that we are
alone in this universe, which is exactly
what this guy said. Now, the guy in the
clip, he's actually a Bible believing
Christian.
This guy right here, he believes in God,
and he's about to find out that she does
not believe in God because she's a
scientist. But it's him that says if all
that space is out there, it'd be an
awful waste of space if there's nothing
else out there. Now, that's I I asked
Google, what is the number one reason
given that people believe that aliens
exist? I already knew the answer, but I
wanted to get proof. And it says the
number one reason given for believing
the existence of aliens is the vastness
and the age of the universe. Now, most
Christians know that science textbooks
are lying about the age, right? We know
this world has only been here for 6,000
years. All of creation, this this
universe in the beginning when God
created the heavens and the earth was
6,000 years ago, but we know that
textbooks lie and say, "Oh, you know,
Earth's billions of years old and it
started trillions of years before that.
We don't know where it started but it
started with some cosmic bang that's
expanding right so the age of the
universe and the vastness
the vastness is a new concept a new idea
and now it's shifted people's minds into
believing there has to be aliens out
there has to be it'd be a waste of space
if not now the new movie coming out by
Stephen Spielberg another uh predictive
programming propaganda piece
is called Disclosure Day. And in the
movie, the same thing happens. You have
a Christian, someone that represents a
Christian, a nun, saying this.
Why would he make such a vast universe
yet save it only for us?
>> All right, you're seeing a common theme
here, right? They keep putting that idea
out there. This universe is so vast,
it's it's ridiculous to think we're
alone. And in this movie, they also have
notice what's um on the little girl's
walls here.
It's hard to see, but her walls are
covered with butterflies. All
butterflies all over her walls. I don't
know what else is in there. There's
probably a lot of other things when the
movie comes out.
But again the symbolism I want to make a
comparison between Ellie in the movie
and Avi Lo.
So Dr. Ellie Arowway, that's the
character in the movie, is a brilliant,
determined protagonist of Carl Sean's
novel and the 1997 film Contact, a
radioastronomer who leads the SETI
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
program and becomes the first human to
make contact with extraterrestrial life
after detecting a complex alien alien
message
from the star Vega,
played by Jody Foster in the film. She's
known for her relentless pursuit of
truth, challenging scientific and
societal barriers to bridge the gap
between scientific
faith and humanity's place in the
cosmos.
Okay? So, think about all those things.
She's she's um she works with SETI. She
heard some kind of she detected some
kind of message and she's on a
relentless pursuit of truth challenging
scientific and societal barriers to
bridge the gap between science faith and
h humanity. That's exactly what Avi Lo,
if you have not seen him, go back and
watch some of our videos. I've done two
videos at least on Avi. Look up the
three Atlas videos. You'll see this guy.
He's been on the news every single day,
every day saying they're hiding
something from us. This is alien. The
government's hiding something. So, look
what it says. Ai Lobe is a prominent
Israeli American theoretical physicist,
astrophysicist, and cosmologist at
Harvard University. known for his
groundbreaking research leadership roles
like heading Harvard astronomy
departments link 20 thou oh uh that's
the link I guess 2011 through 2020 black
hole initiative institute for theory and
computation
and Galileo project and controversial
theories particularly his hypothesis
that the first interstellar object was
alien technology which he actively
investigates through his project. He's a
best-selling author of books like
extraterrestrial advocating
like extraterrestrial advocating for a
serious scientific search for
extraterrestrial intelligence or SETI.
So he he works with SETI and he thinks
that comets are actually UFOs in
disguise and all this stuff. You got to
go check it out because when they were
pushing this whole Threeey Atlas thing,
he was the one that was on the news
every day saying, "This thing is an
alien ship in disguise. It's doing
things like changing color and
accelerating the way it shouldn't and
plumes are coming off of it and this
thing is not normal and it's way too
big. There's not enough space dust to
make a comet the size of Manhattan."
That's what he was saying. So, this is
predictive programming. This movie is
predictive programming about Avi Lobe.
Now, this is the playbook that the elite
are using. Ellie Arowway, Jodie Foster
hears an alien signal from Vega. This is
what the movie says. She tries to alert
authorities. NASA, NSA, and the
government dismiss it as a hoax, natural
phenomenon, or a comet, which is exactly
what's happening right now. When Avi Lo
says that this is alien, then next thing
you know, NASA comes on and says, "Oh,
this is this is normal." Then he comes
back on and says, "No, it's not." And
they say, "Yes, it is." So, there's this
back and forth thing. Then media
controlled leaks start trickling out.
Remember, anything on the controlled
mainstream propaganda source is not a
true whistleblower. It's not a true
leak. This is what they want you to
believe. If it's on mainstream media
television, this is what the elite want
you to follow and believe. So don't fall
for the quote unquote leaks.
Public pressure forces the government to
build the alien machine in the movie.
We're going to go into that. And the
public feels like they won, but the
whole thing was allowed by design. A
slow roll revelation uh orchestrated
from above. So,
in the movie, they decode a message that
has to do with building a machine where
you can actually communicate with the
aliens. All right, we're going to get
into it, but this is crazy.
>> What is this? This is a personal
vendetta now.
>> It's not just Drumland. There's been
enormous pressure from other scientists
as well. These are government-owned
telescopes. They can lease them to
whomever they want, and they don't want
the high priestess of the desert using
them anymore. staring at static on TV
for hours at a time, listening to
washing machines. Did you really think
these stories wouldn't get around?
>> I was looking for patterns in the chaos.
Come on.
>> It doesn't matter anymore. We're a joke
to them. They want us out. We've got 3
months until the paperwork goes through.
We lost. It's over.
>> If I have to go it alone, I'll go it
alone. I've done it before.
>> So, they're defunding her because
they're saying, "You're you're the
laughingtock of the science world. We're
not going to keep giving you money just
to sit there and listen to dead air all
day long. And she's like, "If I got to
do this alone, I'm going to." So, she's
resilient just like Avi Lobe. I asked,
"Does Avi Lo say that NASA is hiding the
truth of extraterrestrial life?" And it
says, "Yes, Harvard astrophysicist Avi
Loe has strongly implied and even
accused NASA of withholding potentially
crucial images of the interstellar
object threeey atlas that could support
his theory that it's an alien probe,
citing a scientific high resolution Mars
reconcer
MRO image from October 2025 that hasn't
been released, attributing the the delay
way to bureaucratic excuses like a
government shutdown while suggesting
NASA knows more. He literally said that
during this threeey atlas thing, the
government shut down and he was saying,
"Look, they shut down because NASA's a
government agency and they don't want to
show you the pictures that these things
that this thing is a alien ship." And so
I asked, do people think Avi Loe, the
scientific community, do they think he's
a nut? Basically, Avi Lobe, a highly
credentialed theoretical astrophysicist
and former chair of the astronomy
department at Harvard University, holds
a controversial position within the
scientific community. While his peers
acknowledge his past significant
contributions to mainstream cosmology,
his recent high-profile claims about
finding alien technology are largely
rejected and have led many to view him
as a sensationalist.
The consensus among most scientists is
that Loe's claims lack significant
evidence and his approach is seen as a
departure from the scientific method.
That's exactly what we just saw in the
movie. Like they the scientific
community thinks you're a waste of time.
This is there's not even any kind of
scientific method behind what you're
doing. We're just pumping money into
this thing. And today, that's what we
have happening with Avi Loe.
>> My guest tonight is author and
theologian Palmer Joss. He's become a
spiritual counselor of sorts in a recent
fixture at the White House. God's
diplomat according to the New York
Times. His latest book, Losing Faith, is
currently number one on that
publication's bestseller list. Thanks
for being with us, Palmer. You have had
quite a ride this last couple years.
>> Yeah, I sure have. Larry,
>> are you anti technology? Are you
anti-cience?
>> No, not at all. The question that I'm
asking is this. Are we happier as a
human race? It is the world
fundamentally a better place because of
science and technology.
>> We shop at home. when we search the web
at the same time we feel emptier lonier
and more cut off from each other than at
any other time in history we're trying
to synthesize society
looking for the meaning what is the
meaning we have jobs we take frantic
vacations we have finance trips to to
the mall to buy more things that we
think are going to fill these these
these holes in our lives is wonder that
we lost opposite direction
So, here's where she, you know,
she's been defunded, but she's still out
here listening. And finally, a signal
comes through. But the reason I showed
what was happening on the television is
because her new friend who's a Christian
Bible believing believes in God, he's on
national television saying, "Yes, I
believe in God and no, I don't think
that, you know, science is bad, but
really has it done anything good for our
spiritual life." All right, this is
going to tie in because this movie is
one of the biggest propaganda pieces
I've ever seen where it's really you
it's leading you into thinking that
she's on a good journey. Like by the end
of the movie, I don't want to spoil it,
but by the end of the movie, she
actually starts to believe that there's
something out there. There's something
beyond this physical realm. And so, as a
viewer, you're like, "Yay, she believes
in God now." But it is a false gospel.
You're going to find out. So the signal
that she's hearing, they said it comes
from Vega. So I asked what is what is
the esoteric significance to the star
Vega? Esoterically, Vega signifies
divine harmony. Remember we heard about
harmony and balance with good and evil,
right? spiritual awakening or the age of
Aquarius, the golden age, the
externalization of the hierarchy and
creative expression often linked to the
celestial lyra for inspiration,
intuitive clarity and emotional healing
through its calming blue white light.
It's seen as a gateway to higher
consciousness.
Vega is seen as a gateway to higher
consciousness
connected to ancient myths of forbidden
love, spiritual protection and cosmic
alignment acting as a powerful catalyst
for personal transformation and deep
inner listening. This is all about
Christ consciousness. This is all about
entering the age of Aquarius Vega. That
was not by accident. It's you're going
to see it come up again. So here we see
that she's actually now the the White
House is listening to what she's saying.
She's telling the government, I I heard
something. This isn't normal. They're
starting to pay attention to her.
They're listening for themselves. Okay,
it sounds like something. And then
President Bill Clinton gets on and he
kind of brushes it off like it's
natural. And she's like, what? And so
there's this little back and forth thing
going on. And finally the people cry out
and they're saying we believe it's
something. And so the news finally
starts to say, "Okay, this this isn't
natural. We don't know what this is, but
it's it's something." Okay, that's
what's happening in our life today. We
got the military saying, "We don't know
what it is. We don't these crafts that
fly around. It's not our technology.
It's not their technology. What is it?"
And then they start saying, "We
communicate with interdimensional
beings, non-human intelligences." All
right. They they got a message. It was a
scrambled picture on a screen, but by
the time they put it together, it was
this.
>> Those look like engineering schematics,
almost like blueprints.
>> It is our belief that the message
contains instructions for building
something. Some kind of machine
>> that does what, doctor?
>> Well, we don't know. It might be some
type of uh advanced communication
device. Or it could be a teaching
machine of some kind. Or uh it might
turn out to be some kind of a transport.
>> Transport. The fact is, you don't know
what it does. could be a Trojan horse.
We build it, not pours the entire Vagan
army.
>> There's no reason to believe that their
intentions are hostile.
>> Why is it the default position of the
Egghehead set that aliens would always
be benign? Why is that, doctor?
>> We pose no threat to them.
>> I just thought this was interesting. You
know, it's pushing the idea that these
beings are good. They're our friends.
There's no reason that we should believe
that they're evil, but they're
Okay, think about this biblically, okay?
beings from the heavens are coming to
people on earth, communicating with
people on earth and giving them
technology. All right, we know as
Christians, I hope everybody here knows
that the whole alien thing are demons in
disguise. Satan is trying to deceive the
entire world by creating a whole
mythology about himself as I'm just a
visitor from another world. I'm not a
demon. I'm not an angel. I'm a I'm a
enlightened evolved being that's come
here to help you and give you technology
and wisdom and knowledge just like the
serpent in the garden. A reptilian
creature came to Eve and said, "I'll
give you wisdom. I'll open your eyes.
You'll become like God. You'll evolve."
Again, she's having the conversation
with this Christian dude and and this is
what they say.
>> I got one for you razor. You ever heard
of it? Basic scientific principle. And
it says, "All things being equal, the
simplest explanation has to be the right
one." So, it's more likely.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> An all powerful, mysterious God created
the universe and then decided not to
give any proof of his existence or that
he simply doesn't exist at all and that
we created him so we wouldn't have to
feel so small and alone.
>> I couldn't imagine living in a world
where God didn't exist, you know.
>> So, she's she's talking about AAM's
razor, you know, and she's saying what
is the simplest explanation? Is it this,
you know, some magical god in the sky
just created people or that by natural
occurrences we evolved and all this
stuff? So, they are opposites. Notice
he's wearing white, she's wearing black.
I just now noticed this. Thank you,
Lord, for that because that's the
duality. They do everything in symbols
like this. That's the duality. The
merging of good and evil, the merging of
science and spirituality. And I'm not
saying science is bad when it's true,
but there's a lot of pseudocience out
there. And what is coming is alchemy in
this world. What is coming is science
proving
spirituality,
but it's going to be it's going to be a
lie. It's going to be a deception.
There's the duality, the black and
white. He put that jacket on her. This
was so planned. All this was
orchestrated.
Now listen to this clip.
>> Madam Chairman, I have one more
question. Would you consider yourself a
uh a spiritual person?
>> I don't really understand the point of
the question. Uh I consider myself a
moral person.
>> Do you believe in God? Dr.
>> As a scientist, I uh rely on empirical
evidence and uh in this matter, I I
don't believe that there is data either
way.
>> So your answer would in fact be that you
don't believe in God. I I just I don't
understand the relevance of the
question.
>> Dr. Arowway, 95% of the world's
population believes in a supreme being
in one form or another. I believe that
makes the question more than relevant.
>> Dr. Ado, I believe um I believe I've
already answered that question.
>> So what happened was they found out what
the blueprint is. The blueprint is to
build some huge machine. It's like
stories tall. It's like a big gyroscope
and it is a CERN machine. It's it's a
spiritual gateway. It's a a Stargate, if
you will. And she desperately wants to
go in there, but they're trying to
figure out who are we going to send. And
they end up deciding on this old
astronaut guy because he believes in
God. They asked her, he asked, "Do you
believe in God?" And she said, "No, I'm
a scientist. I don't believe in God."
And so they're like, "Well, we think if
somebody's going to have first contact
with aliens,
they should be someone that believes in
God. 95% of the world believes in God."
This is very interesting. This whole
movie, I'm telling you, this is the
biggest psychological operation,
predictive programming, all about what
we're about to face. We are about to
face a one world religion.
one world religion with that even
atheists can believe in scientists
because science is going to prove that
the spirit world exists
and it's it's alchemy science and
sorcery together science and
spirituality.
This is coming.
So, here's the machine that was built
this big gyroscope thing. And she is
inside of a a sphere.
And while she's inside this sphere above
the gyroscope, they're going to drop the
sphere in the middle of the gyroscope
when it's at its fastest spin and see
what happens because that's what the
blueprints told them to do. Oh, by the
way, the reason she's in there is
because the first guy they chose, the
machine fell apart and I he died. And so
she was actually contacted secretly by
somebody else and said, "We're going to
make you go in it now." And she couldn't
wait to go in it. So she's in this
Stargate.
What is she doing? She wants to
communicate. Remember, she's been trying
to communicate with her dead mom, her
dead dad, and now she wants to
communicate with these beings that she
doesn't even know what they are.
as far as going inside of a machine that
could open up a wormhole and let you
communicate with interdimensional
beings. This is not space travel. You're
going to find out this is not space
travel. This is about interdimensional
travel. Watch.
Oh god,
it's a star. I must have gone through a
wormhole.
It's
po. [laughter]
I should have said the poem. So
beautiful.
So beautiful. So beautiful. I had no
idea. I had no idea.
Hi, Sparks.
>> Dad,
>> I missed you.
>> Somebody uh Linda for Christ just said
that movie is in my home and it's going
to be removed from my home. It should
be. Look, I used to love sci-fi. I still
do, but it's like you can't watch
anything. This movie was all about
communication with the dead,
communicating with demons by using
technology, interdimensional portals.
So, she was in the machine.
She did not go to space. A wormhole
opened up. She saw Vega, which we just
read about Vega, right? Vega was all
about this star that's about
enlightenment.
Vega is Lucifer.
and she sees Vega and she goes, "Oh,
it's so beautiful. I I have no words. I
have no words. It's so beautiful." And
she's getting her emotions wrapped up.
Satan is a master at manipulating
emotions. Do you know that Satan can use
music to manipulate your emotions and
make you get goosebumps and feel in
love? You could take a Hill Song song
and replace all the words with praises
to Satan and you would still feel
euphoric and the goosebumps and the
emotions because it's the music that's
emotional.
Satan loves to use emotional
manipulation. That's why he has all
these false flags where children are
shot in schools and things like that.
It's all emotional manipulation. That's
why this movie is communicating with her
dad. It's to trap you, to pull on your
heartstrings, to make you fall for the
story. The propaganda that's wrapped up
in this movie. What is wrapped up in
this movie is she entered into
a Stargate.
She traveled interdimensionally, not
through space,
and she saw her dead dad who's actually
an alien manifesting as her dad
or they don't know. They never really
explain is it alien. It's alien in the
sense that it's not of this world. Now,
she finds out that she didn't go
anywhere. When they watch the video, she
fell right through.
GOT VIDEO ON ELLIE. 5X5.
>> How long was I gone?
>> Ellie, the IPV dropped straight through
the machine.
>> You didn't go anywhere.
>> They're telling her,
"We didn't see you go anywhere." And
she's like, "No, I was gone for like 8
hours."
8, something like that. She was gone for
hours and hours and hours, but when they
show her the video, the ball goes
straight through and splashes in the
water.
Now, this is manipulation of space and
time and all this stuff. It's
interdimensional. It's not space travel.
[snorts] Now, she's going to court.
They're having a court hearing over this
thing because they're trying to figure
out is she
is she just uh lying about all this
because they don't it's her word against
theirs and this is a scientific
community and they're funding money for
this thing and and she's saying
something is real. This is we I need
your money. I need the funding and this
is real. And they're saying they start
to use her own logic against her, the
scientific logic. Oh, have you ever
heard of AAM's razor? Listen to this.
>> Doctor, are you familiar with the
scientific precept known as AAM's razor?
>> Yes.
It means that all things being equal,
the simplest explanation tends to be the
right one.
>> Exactly. You tell me, what is more
likely here? that a message from aliens
results in a magical machine that whisks
you away to the center of the galaxy to
go wind surfing with dear old dad and
then a split second later returns you
home without a single shred of proof or
that your experience is the result of
being the unwitting star in the farewell
performance of one SR Haden, a man with
the means, the motive and the
opportunity to play you and indeed the
rest of us as pawns in the biggest, the
most elaborate, the most expensive hoax
of all time.
>> Are you really going to sit there and
tell us we should just take this all on
faith? So now they're questioning, do
you want us to all just take this on
faith? They're questioning her and she's
saying,"I I experienced something. I had
an experience that I can't prove to you
guys." This is like what happens when
you become a Christian, right? I gave my
heart to God. I know he's real because
I've experienced him. I have a
testimony. My life has changed, but I
can't prove it to anyone else. This is
where it's a slippery slope. This is
where it gets super tricky because now
you've fallen for this emotional story
that has to do with necromancy and
communication with demons, but now she's
believing. Now she's become a believer
in something more than just the physical
realm. So now as a watcher, you're
saying, "Oh, I I'm I'm happy for her.
She finally believes." But what does she
believe in? What is the movie's message
pushing? That you should believe in a
god that has to do with
interdimensional travel and
communication with the dead
and falling for the alien deception.
>> Then why don't you simply withdraw your
testimony and concede that this journey
to the center of the galaxy in fact
never took place?
>> Because I can't I can't prove it. I
can't even explain it. But everything
that I know as a human being, everything
that I am, tells me that it was real. I
was given something wonderful, something
that changed me forever. A vision that
tells us undeniably how tiny and
insignificant and how rare and precious
we all are.
A vision that tells us that we belong to
something that is greater than
ourselves, that we are not, that none of
us are alone.
>> Josh, what do you believe?
>> What do you believe?
As a person of faith, I'm bound by a
different covenant than Dr. Airway.
>> But our goal is one and the same.
>> The pursuit of truth.
I for one believe her.
>> So that's the end of the movie. The end
of the movie is the spiritual person who
believes in God uniting with the
scientific person who didn't believe in
God, but now she does because science
proved something spiritual, but it was a
deceptive spirituality. It was about
Vega, interdimensional beings,
communication with the dead. And this is
where you have the duality.
See, none of this was by accident. Her
name being the lightbearer, the
checkerboard floor, the allseeing eye,
the owl, the butterflies, the name
divine spark, which is thenosticism.
All of this was perfectly precisely done
to predict what we are living in right
now. This was a predictive programming
piece. So in reality, right now we see a
lobe doing the same thing. claims that
alien spacecraft or tech has already
arrived.
Um, the government denies everything
publicly. Oh, it's just comets. It's
space junk. Nothing to see here.
Meanwhile, approved whistleblowers like
David Grush and some other people are
shown on mainstream news, 60 Minutes,
CNN, etc. leaking secrets. The public is
baited into demanding the truth. See, we
are being tricked into thinking, "Wait,
I saw the leak. I know you're hiding
something." We demand to know the truth.
And that gives Satan power. When we give
Satan an invitation, we want to know. We
welcome it. Tell us the truth. We want
to see the aliens. We want to know.
Now, Satan has permission to reveal
himself to humanity. This is how crazy
this SCOP is. It's a spiritual legal
system. Satan needs permission and he
has to trick us into giving him
permission. And that's what's happening
right now. The quote unquote truth is
actually the deception. Aliens are real,
advanced, and peaceful and coming. It's
the perfect Hegelian dialectic. The
problem create the problem. Strange
phenomenon. UAPs
give a solution or a reaction is the
government cover up versus whistleblower
truth. You got this. Do we believe the
government or do we believe the
whistleblower? But the solution, the
public unites to demand disclosure,
which is actually spiritual surrender to
demons posing as aliens.
So, here's a here's a comparison
of Ellie in the movie and Avi Loe.
They're both rogue scientist archetype
who delivers revelation outside of
official channels.
Alien as her father familiar spirits in
disguise. False comfort, emotional
manipulation,
transmission from Vega. Vega equals the
fallen star. Symbolism, possibly a
reference to Lucifer the lightbearer.
Government denial versus secret machine
construction. Two-faced system
suppression publicly, revelation
privately, one world cooperation,
predictive programming for new world
order through ET unification. This is
exactly what Reagan said. how quickly
our differences would go away and we
could all unite and unify if we were
threatened by some outside alien threat.
Faith in science versus faith in God.
Spiritual hijacking science is now your
church.
Alchemy,
science, and spiritualism put together.
I'm going to show you that this is
already happening.
I did a video on this kid who saw Jesus.
He had a surgery. He was on ketamine.
Nobody said that in the beginning.
They're just like, "This kid saw Jesus."
And he's crying and it has to be Jesus.
But we found out that he I already knew
when I watched it. He's out of his mind.
He's like, "Hi, Jesus. I want Dave's hot
chicken." You know, and he's saying all
this stuff. My name's not He He didn't
even know his name. He didn't know his
name. He's talking about one chicken and
and just because he saw Jesus and his
dead dad,
people got emotional and they fell for
it and they said, "This has to be real
and you're actually evil for questioning
it." But this kid was on ketamine. He
was coming off a ketamine because he
just had a surgery from a skateboarding
accident. And look what ketamine does.
>> Ketamine seems to induce these mystical
experiences. Sometimes it might be
feeling connected with universe, with
God, angels, and it can be quite
otherworldly during the ketamine
infusion experience. And what's really
powerful about that is sometimes when we
connect with a higher part of us,
something beyond what it means to be
just a normal human being, but kind of
tapping into that metaphysical other
dimensional world. Whether it's true or
not, it can be quite profound during the
ketamine infusion journey.
Yeah. So, he's right there on it talking
about um being in this other realm and
stuff. Now, this was a long video. I'm
not going to play the whole thing, but
the ver the very beginning she gets into
ketamine and talking to the dead and
stuff. This whole video is called um
dead relative scene while on ketamine.
Is there a link between psychedelics?
That's what the name of the video is.
Um they they tell me I felt myself
floating
and then they look really confused and
then I ask them I'm like well um is
there something more? And then they tell
me yes um my body I know my body is in
the chair and I'm holding on to the the
side of the recliner but I know my I'm
separate from my body so I guess it's
their consciousness.
>> Um and I tell them yes that's exactly
that's exactly correct. I go, "So, that
was your psychedelic trip." Um, then
they, you know, they tell they tell me
these like other worldly things like I
saw relatives that were deceased. I saw
um ancestors, they saw where they went
on vacation maybe the year before with
somebody that was no longer with them.
Um, what else?
They were flying. It's just different
stories. So, kind of um if somebody was
making up fairy tales, I guess it's kind
of sounds like that, but I I know from
from having to experience the we do an
experiential treatment as part of our
job. Our doctor believes that we need to
be in our patients shoes to understand
to explain to them to keep that sentence
setting sacred for them.
So, I just wanted to show that that this
is a very very common thing that happens
on ketamine that you heard it from the
doctor.
>> Okay. I I wish I had that whole clip.
I'm going to I'm going to find that
whole clip. This lady Well, first it
showed a clip from a doctor. He gives
ketamine to patients to for overcoming
uh depression and all these things. And
they say you should you should come for
six visits like once a week or
something. And they say people get off
their antid-depressant medicines, but
they float out of their body. They see
angels. They see Jesus. They see dead
loved ones. Now, this lady, she said, "I
don't I I'm a scientist. I don't believe
in spiritual things or whatever, but I'm
starting to because I've I give the
patient ketamine. I go around into
another room and I watch them through a,
you know, a two oneway mirror and I
start seeing these flying orbs enter
their body. She says, "It's not dust.
These things are flying around like
they're cognitive."
And these orbs fly into the person's
body. She sees it on infrared and then
she asks them, "What what happened? What
was going on in there?" And they said,
"Oh, I saw my my dead daughter." This
one lady, she said, "I can't wait to
come back every week or every month or
whatever it is every week because I get
to visit with my dead daughter." And
every time she does, this lady is seeing
orbs on an infrared camera and now she
believes because science is proving
spiritualism.
But it's not a true spiritualism because
these people aren't really blasting out
of their bodies. They're not really
going to heaven or seeing dead loved
ones. The dead know nothing. The dead
praise not the Lord. The dead are dead
until Christ returns and they are
resurrected from their graves to be
judged. This is why it's so important to
understand what happens when you die.
Because any communication with the dead
is a demonic deception. And yet right
now this is becoming normalized
to take drugs. This is this is uh
shamanism.
being pushed into western society as
medicine. Instead of going out to the
jungle and having a shaman bang on some
drums and drinking some stuff and you
puke everywhere, they have people in
white lab coats with rubber gloves and
they inject it into your veins and the
same thing happens. You fly out of your
body. You have a ego death. You see your
dead loved ones. You get closure on
things and you come back a changed
person and now you are a disciple for
sharing the demonic deceptions of what
you've experienced.
It's happening now guys. It's happening
now. I could wrap it up right there, but
I wanted to just show a couple little
things that I thought were interesting
because this movie
where she met her dad was on the beach
and I noticed that this is a common
theme with these Gnostic movies. There
was a movie called Dark City and it was
a Gnostic movie where he was in a false,
you know, he was in a a false world like
the Matrix and a, you know, he broke out
of that and notice there's a woman at
the end of this dock. At the end of this
movie, when he finally breaks free,
there's
like a beach scene and a woman. This is
a movie called 13th Floor. Another
Gnostic movie with the same idea, kind
of like The Matrix, like you're breaking
free. And for some reason, there's this
beach scene just like we saw in Contact.
Uh another movie called The Island, a
Gnostic movie where, you know,
everybody's wearing white. They were in
this perfect world and they thought the
outside world was contaminated until
they broke free. And again, the water.
Now, the Truman show was the same thing.
He reached the edge of this water and
walked out of a door into utter
darkness. Just like Dark City, there was
a door into utter darkness. And in the
13th floor, there was a door that goes
into this whatever [clears throat] that
looks like dark space.
There's always this ocean and a door out
into outer darkness. This is nasticism.
If you haven't seen it before, check out
Little Light Studios. There's a lot of
videos on Gnostic themes and movies. I
hope you guys are blessed by this. I
hope it made sense. I hope I was able to
articulate it because this is predictive
programming 100%. We are living in the
movie Contact right now where they are
talking about merging
the scientific world, the spiritual
world, and aliens all together. We're
about to find out that aliens aren't
really just visitors from another world,
but they're actually interdimensional
beings. But they exclude the truth that
these are fallen angels, demonic
deceivers. They exclude that part and
sell it as this is science. You can take
this ketamine and you can talk to these
beings. We found the chemical. We found
the alchemal alchemical potion that
connects you to the divine. This movie
was all about it. If you enjoyed this
video, please, please, please give a
thumbs up. It really helps the
algorithm. I see that there's like 90
something people in here at one point.
Please give a thumbs up. Share this
video with your family and friends
because we are living in some crazy
times. Go check out some of our other
videos about the threeey atlas, about
the ketamine stuff, and about where
we're headed in this grand age of
deception. If you would like to support
this ministry, you can do so by going to
cantruth.org.
We got a lot of different platforms you
can give on, including Patreon, and we
have a lot of cool merch that you can
buy stuff from, and we get $5 roughly
per sale on that. And it really helps.
and you can wear some cool t-shirts that
have the truth on it and that are a
great conversation starter. If you have
been giving to this ministry, thank you
so so much. We see you. We love you. We
try to reach out to every person. Some
platforms don't let us reach out. I
think uh Zel and Vinmo, but we see you.
We love you. We can't do this without
you. And we'll see you next time on
Candid Truth.